klar einblick wie in dieser verlust aus
der bahn geworfen
seine songs könnten manchmal ereignisse
vorwegnehmen wie träume
sagt nick cave einmal im dokumentarfilm
der ursprünglich nur die musik aufnahmen
zum neuen album begleiten sollte
es kommt
wisst ihr
dieser song den er bereits geschrieben
hatte bekommt im nachhinein eine ganz
neue bedeutung
und der film wird zum ventil für case
trauerarbeit nahe seines wohnorts im
südenglischen brighton passierte das
große unglück der 15-jährige sohn
stürzte vergangenen sommer unter lsd
einfluss von den kreidefelsen
die aufnahmen hatten da erst begonnen
ein zu starker schlag auch für einen
überlebenskünstler wenig es ist er ist
blockiert und stellt alles was bisher
galt in frage
carlsdorf ii
mit
so redet er nun vor der kamera über die
folgen des dramas obwohl er lieber nur
seine songs sprechen ließ seine frau
susie und office zwillingsbruder schirmt
er von der öffentlichkeit ab so gut er
kann
45 uhr/sky
red
beinahe unerträglich für ihn diese
prophetischen zeilen zu singen nach dem
schweren verlust düster karg beinahe
nackt sind die aufnahme geraten
so wie er immer elegant angezogener
autor hier auch vor seinem publikum sein
innerstes entblößt der film fängt diese
ganz besondere magie ein eine art
requiem als flüchtiger moment an einem
einzigen abend in den kinos gezeigt
m
das neue album skeleton tree aber bleibt
ein musikalisches zeugnis dieser zeit
nick caves großes trauer album
nochmal mit viel gefühl
dieser song wird einen so schnell nicht
wieder loslassen
wie nick cave und auf der künstler und
choreograf ohad naharin den verlust
seien